chapter two billionaire boardroom
session with lord sugar
my plans of owning a thousand properties
was always applauded by my mentors and
peers i'd also become very popular in
the media as i symbolized youthful
entrepreneurialism i was approached by
many people from all walks of life who
wanted to pat me on the back and pick my
brain about property investment
within a matter of months of finding a
new mentor i'd become richer than they
were my portfolio was rising in value
and i was leveraging the equity to buy
more and more houses
as a byproduct of finding good property
deals for myself i was packaging and
selling hundreds of property investment
deals and using the money to expand my
own portfolio
every time i had a strategy session with
my mentor i would far surpass the
targets that were set
i spent a small fortune on hiring new
coaches who could help me raise the bar
even higher
it was a struggle to find people who
were more successful than i was or whom
i would not overtake very quickly
that changed when i received an
invitation to attend a business
conference where lord sugar would be
speaking
i thought it'd be a good idea to attend
as i've never met lord sugar and he was
a billionaire who held most of his
wealth in real estate
before booking tickets i rang up the
event organizers and explained that i
really wanted an opportunity to sit down
with lord sugar
and get some bespoke guidance on my
business plan to own a thousand homes
to my surprise
they said yes
so long as i paid four thousand eight
hundred pounds i'd be able to sit down
around a table for at least an hour with
only five other business owners and ask
lord sugar any personal questions i had
relevant to my business
i immediately paid the money as i
thought this was a rare opportunity that
could prove priceless
after all i thought he must know
something more than i do because his
bank balance is bigger than mine
so on november the 10th 2017 i found
myself sitting around a private
boardroom table with lord sugar at the
heathrow airport hilton hotel
confidently ready to present my business
plan
i was a little nervous because i'd seen
him on the tv so many times ruthlessly
ripping people to shreds in boardrooms
but this was different i had a solid
business plan i was rapidly making money
and my property portfolio was burning
lord sugar picked up his pen
looked me straight in the eye and said
tell me about your business
i didn't see this as a case of me
pitching to him or trying to impress him
it was simply my chance to see how i
could tweak improve or fast track my
goal of ultimately owning a thousand
houses
i explained where i was as an
entrepreneur
lord sugar i'm in the real estate
business i already have a million
property portfolio of residential
properties mostly consisting of single
family homes and hmos
i'm currently making a minimum of ten
thousand pounds a month packaging and
selling property investments to other
investors as well and using this money
to put down more deposits on properties
to scale up my portfolio
my target
is to own 1 000 houses
i was waiting for lord sugar to pack me
on the backing tell me how well i've
done for a 26 year old
oh how wrong i was
he pulled a face as if he'd just swicked
a bottle of vinegar or sucked a bag of
lemons
why on earth would you want to he said
i was shocked
i couldn't believe he was saying this
when he himself was a property
billionaire
i assume he must be talking about the
deal packaging as i've mentioned maybe
he didn't like the idea of selling deals
to other investors i began to explain
how deal sourcing worked and how much
money i was making by providing a
service for investors who didn't have
the time or inclination to find their
own investments
he looked over my plans and said that
the deal sourcing made sense he seemed
relatively impressed with that side of
things but he couldn't get over the idea
of me wanting to own
a thousand homes
he said
owning a thousand houses means owning a
thousand boilers too
what are you gonna do when the boiler
keeps breaking down and the tenants keep
on calling you i can't imagine it would
be very profitable
unfazed i showed him my profit margins
and i explained to him how my hmo
properties made enough profit to cover
maintenance i outlined my power team how
the whole process was systemized and how
this led to good profit margins he
seemed to warm to me as a person but he
remained cool on the idea of owning so
many properties he kept emphasizing how
big a headache it would be and there
were far better ways to invest in real
estate
this was a really hard pill for me to
swallow as i was so focused and
determined to continue to scale my
portfolio i'd been doing
however i decided not to argue and just
listen
lord sugar was not being a jerk or
acting provocatively for the sake of it
he was trying to help me
there were no video cameras or tv
audience in the room he was speaking
from experience and he knew far more
than i did about being a property
billionaire
blood sugar made me realize that my
target of owning so many houses
was more of an ego thing
i just wanted to be able to say it had a
great ring to it a thousand houses but
really
any smart business person will tell you
that the target in business
should be simply to make as much profit
as possible the goal should not be to
own as many houses as possible but to
make as much money as possible
property was the vehicle
to generate profit not the other way
around
i learned that day
that nearly every property billionaire
invests in big deals
you have to scale up and increase the
size of your deals
not the number of them
i've never met anybody who owns more
than 100 houses who's also a smart
business person
small deals require
just as much effort
and work as big deals
but big deals make far more profit
the thing that makes you financially
comfortable is not the thing that makes
you a millionaire
and the thing that makes you a
millionaire
is not the thing that makes you a
billionaire
i now needed to stop what i was doing
and start playing a whole new game
lord sugar had shattered my business
plan but had handed me a new monopoly
board